c'est devenu un rituel une méditation
quotidienne prendre son café sur sa
terrasse en se remémorant ses années
fastes n'est plus le cavalier qu'il
était autrefois c'est qu'il y a un an il
a eu un thrombus un caillot de sang dans
la jambe
un problème qui se règle facilement 6-1
chirurgie cardio-vasculaire vous prend
en charge en moins de six heures on n'a
pas eu cette chance
selon marguerite fraser la médecin qui a
reçu ou acteurs à leur chance l'ablation
aurait dû être évité car normalement
dans un hôpital régional comme celui où
elle travaille
il y à ce genre de spécialistes sur
place dès situation impensable au canada
mais en moins de nom la région du cap
breton a perdu 20 % de son personnel
médical dont ses deux chirurgien
cardiovasculaire les salaires des
médecins nouvelle écosse sont plus bas
que la moyenne nationale depuis des
années et le système se dégradent
constamment
selon l'économiste richard seyant seul
ottawa pu sauver les meubles
ce qu'on voit c'est que les provinces
qui sont prouve comme dans les maritimes
on essaie quand même de t'arriver
philippe fiscal parce qu'on est
surendetté et on peut plus continuer de
s'endetter mais ce qui se produit c'est
qu'on coupe de la santé au monde
n'investit pas dans la santé la
croissance démographique ici entre 2011
et 2016 était de 0 2 % alors que la
moyenne nationale était de 5 % la
proportion de personnes âgées partout en
atlantique est beaucoup plus élevé que
dans le reste du pays
la pénurie d'employés forcent la
fermeture de certains services des
centres hospitaliers et de cliniques en
trois mois c'est plus de 2000 heures de
fermeture dans la région du maghreb
16h03 que la qualité des soins aux
patients on prend un sérieux coup en
sait quelque chose
ce cri du coeur et les lance en pleine
campagne électorale n'a pas autre chose
car selon lui même si sa province reçoit
un peu plus de 2 milliards de dollars en
transferts en santé d'ottawa pour une
population de 900 mille personnes
c'était suffisant pour faire face à la
crise richard saillants crois en effet
que les transferts devrait être calculé
selon les besoins uniques de chacune des
provinces et non par habitant une région
comme les maritimes a connu une
croissance de son peignoir transfert
d'environ 4%
si vous regardez nos provinces comme
l'alberta plus jeunes beaucoup plus
riches mais aussi qui vieillit beaucoup
plus lentement
le transfert a évolué
arrête de 9% annuellement donc plus de
deux fois plus que les maritimes qui
sont plus vieilles plus vieillissante
les plus pauvres rivés devant son
téléviseur depuis le début de cette
campagne
bordeaux aimerait vraiment entendre
parler de transferts en santé par les
politiciens
mais il ne se fait pas d'illusions ici
les à céret radio canada sineo cas
breton